Harold asks will you force your children
to partake in the business like your dad
will you be disappointed if they don't
want to my dad never forced me you know
you hear the story on my dad boy I've
said it my dad forced me into the
business he forced me into the business
as like a 14 year old child child labor
dad but but there was you know my age I
never worked at Wine Library I think one
summer of you if you're listening or
watching AJ I know you worked there one
summer but you know he never worked in
the business I think that you know for
my parents look I was a crap student and
and I was a great like salesman as a kid
like it was such a natural segue to the
impact that that my mom fully believed
in and she was closest to the situation
I have no I'm weird with this issue man
I am I
first of all I'm a dark dude can we go
black and white on this who knew black
and white and darker on the black really
cool I'm a dark dude I we you know they
tell you not to compete with your
children like that's a that's like a top
five flaw in society that will not be
something I'm successful in kids maecius
and I'm sorry I'm here dude
like Xander is two and a half years old
he has a basketball like set up in the
living room and I've blocked every one
of his shots so far like like to the
point where he picks up a ball if I'm in
the room he starts crying just now block
not like this is what Xander does even
if I'm like 10 minutes away because he
knows what's coming which is he's not
scoring until he can score and so you
know I am fine I love my kids
unconditional if there's slow meals and
can't sell water in a desert well then
that's just the way it ended up being
right like Lizzy and I had sex at the
wrong moment if that's something I cared
about like that's what it is
so I just want them to focus on their
strengths I want to put them in a
position to succeed
I think financially and connections wise
there's a very good chance that that's
going to happen and you know you do the
best you can as you know very much the
way I mean a parent has a lot to do with
the way that I that I run companies and
I think that the people have worked for
me and close to me probably feel
happy and feel good about my kids
opportunities because I care and I have
no disappointment if they don't want to
work for at that point the New York Jets
you know and so that's it I mean no I'm
I've no no hesitation I mean if my kids
go completely the other way and and are
not commerce driven and our anti
business and our you know want to live
in
who knows we're feeding who knows what
doing whatever if they want to save the
one-legged butterfly in some God knows
place in the corner of the world I'm
gonna hope that they're the best that's
saving the one-legged butterfly I'm
gonna try to help them save the
one-legged butterfly and sweep register
one-legged butterfly calm
we should I I just will support them
unconditionally as long as they're good
human beings and three people respect
and treat people with the fifty one
forty nine percent thing and be the
bigger man and woman I don't care what
they do as long as they do it in a way
that five thousand arbitrators would say
that's a good person oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe